to dream to seek the unknown to look for  what is beautiful is its own reward a  man's reach should exceed his grasp or  what's a heaven for  you are the Explorer even you have  I wish to find the lost what you seek is  far greater when you ever imagined it is  your thing not know you when you return  I know this is a sacrifice for all the  environments built a difficult the  journey may well mean your life but you  could reclaim your family name  ain't nobody comes back from up there  but we've never let fear determine our  future  it's love to achieve out here  if we may find the hidden civilization  well one was considered impossible to  exist we may well write a whole new  chapter in history I call it death yeah  we're look I guess  you  you